[Musique]
m
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 9 mai
quels sont les liens entre les aires de
jeux pour enfants et certaines formes
présentes dans l'art contemporain
vincent roumanie réfléchi avec le kodomo
no kuni une exposition dont le nom
s'inspire d'un parc pour enfants 2 et 3
ans de restauration intérieure et
extérieure la maison de la reine au
château de versailles va connaître une
nouvelle page de son histoire
des visites guidées permettront de
découvrir ce lieu voulue par marie
antoinette
ils font du cinéma du théâtre les
comédiens de déclic réinvente le
septième art en direct pour improviser
des films que vous ne verrez plus jamais
kodo no kuni veut dire le pays des
enfants en japonais c'est aussi le nom
d'un parc pour enfants au pays du soleil
levant le micro-ondes le centre d'art de
vélizy-villacoublay a proposé au
commissaire vincent romeny de réfléchir
aux liens entre aire de jeux et art
contemporain
regardez
[Musique]
entrez vous aussi dans le conte celui du
japon des enfants et de leur aire de
jeux que vous raconte kodomo no kuni une
exposition pensé par vincent roumanie
c'est à la suite donc il y a deux ans
d'une recherche qui l'a mené à la villa
kujoyama il s'est plus particulièrement
intéressé à l'histoire des aires de jeux
au japon et comment elles s'articulent à
cette histoire spécifique du japon au
regard de la guerre on regarde des
catastrophes naturelles
il s'agit
d'exposition qui positionne davantage
d'artistes au sein de la ville et
questionne l'artiste dans la relation
qu'il établit au sein de la ville et
comment quand il dessine à une aire de
jeu qu'est ce qu'il a souhaité faire une
exposition en deux parties une première
mettant en avant l'histoire des aires de
jeux au japon avec une réplique d'une
aire de mitsuru sanda coproduite par le
micro ondes
mitsuru cndd à inventer des formes
d'heure de jeu remarquable parfois sous
forme de tunnel là c'était un l'un des
sujets qui l'intéressait le tunnel qui
est sûrement une forme organique qui est
fascinante pour l'enfant mais puis là il
s'agit d'un tunnel sous forme de
panneaux puisqu'il s'appelle tunnel
tonnelle panel et dans lequel sont
découper des formes géométriques et que
l'enfant doit traverser la deuxième
partie se distancent de l'air de jeu
praticable ou un vélo aménagé répond à
une grotte de parapluies une exposition
de temps pour deux publics adultes et
enfants pour un voyage vers le pays du
soleil levant
deux ans de travaux pour le bâtiment 3
pour les jardins la maison de la reine
doit se terminer sa restauration
un chantier devenu urgent en raison de
sa vétusté et qui va permettre sa
réouverture au public
regardez plus que quelques jours pour
découvrir ce lieu
la maison de la reine et ses jardins
jacques nous là vous êtes l'architecte
en chef des monuments historiques
le chantier devenait urgent oui la
maison la reine est un des monuments les
plus connus de versailles en a tous
l'image en tête c'est un monument qui
n'a jamais été ouvert au public depuis
son usage comme guinguette durant les
années 1900 donc il y avait
effectivement urgence à la fois retraité
le bâtiment et enfin le présenter un
lieu historique bien sûr qui dénote d
autres un aspect assez rustique avec de
grands jardins
vous savez la palais comme versailles
décline toute une série d'architecturé
différentes
ce hameau c'est un ouvrage très
particulier de la fin du xviiie siècle
dans les jardins à l'anglais dans les
jardins paysagers on sait qu'il y avait
d alternance de moments paysager pays
tôt pittoresque et de fabrique fausses
ruines tombeau construction chinoise de
toute nature le hameau n'appartient pas
du tout à cette famille de fabrique le
hameau est une tradition française qui
s'inscrit
dans la fin d'une époque médiévale elle
s'inscrit dans le rapprochement entre le
bon berger et le pouvoir royal qui
s'occupe de son peuple et vous avez des
fêtes sur le thème du du berger bergère
dès la fin du moyen-âge dans les plus
grandes courses françaises et au 16e
siècle s'est relayée par des laiteries
précieuse au xviie siècle aussi les
bergers d'arcadie tu pousses un toute la
littérature
antic de l'époque il renvoie aussi et au
xviiie siècle s'est relayée par les
physiocrates un mouvement d'économistes
qui définit la production agricole comme
la principale richesse d'un pays et donc
la paysannerie redevient à la mode parce
que finalement c'est d'elle que le pays
le pouvoir et le roi tirent leurs
richesses pour marionnettes ce lieu est
un lieu où elle oublié peut-être le
protocole l'étiquette le hameau est à la
fois un lieu retiré de l'étiquette et du
protocole
c'est aussi un lieu où elle est elle
même où elle dit qu'elle vit en
particulière où elle n'a pas
effectivement les contraintes de la cour
mais c'est aussi également un château ne
vous fiez pas à l'aspect du hameau ça
imite un village normand
mais en réalité vous avez des salon
salle à manger salle de billard de
boudoir un appartement entier pour la
reine une laiterie de préparation une
laiterie propreté bien évidemment les
bâtiments de service le réchauffement
quel nom donner à la cuisine c'est à
dire un vrai château éclaté en une demi
douzaine de bâtiments et un château qui
avait besoin de retrouver une nouvelle
jeunesse sur quoi s'est porté la
restauration l'assainissement des
ouvrages et pour les jardins la chance
vu que nous ayons sur l'amo une très
abondante documentation ça nous vaut des
précisions extraordinaire canto à l'état
du bâtiment autant de marie-antoinette
notamment ses peintures dites en vétusté
pour faire croire qu'elles étaient
anciennes comme sur un décor de théâtre
alors qu'elle venait d'être fait
mais cet état de marie-antoinette n'aura
qu'un temps à peine dix ans à la
révolution arrive elles dégradent
considérablement le bâtiment et c'est
napoléon pour l'impératrice marie louise
qui va restaurer partiellement le hameau
mais qui va également le transformer les
jardinets sont
disparaissent napoléon supprime les
escaliers extérieurs trop souffrant trop
des intempéries il fait qu'ouvrir les
vérandas et les fausses ruines
pittoresque où on prenait la pluie mais
où évidemment rien ne tenait dans le
temps donc il ya une grosse
transformation architecturale aussi bien
à l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur du hameau
et cet état napoléonien va être à son
tour modifié par le temps
ce qui a encore l'air d'un mot sous
napoléon 1er même s'il n'a plus vraiment
la même allure qu'autant de marie
antoinette au fur et à mesure que
poussent les arbres qui sont autour
ça devient la maison de heidi des
chaumières blottis sous d'énormes arbres
qui ont l'air de les manger
le lierre a gagné toutes les maçonneries
et
cette espèce dominante végétale 7 ce
développement des arbres cache en fait
la misère la misère d'un bâtiment
pratiquement en ruines au point qu'on
envisageait de le détruire en 1900 et
vous en tant qu'architecte en chef
quelles étaient vos principales
préoccupations redessiné les jardins
peut-être bien dans cet état extrêmement
dégradé que le début du 20e siècle
découvre au hameau il va y avoir un
sauveur qui va être rockefeller
rockefeller dans la donation qui l'a
fait à versailles a compris des travaux
sur trianon et ou hameaux et ce sont les
travaux du hameau qui vont sauver grâce
à rockefeller le hameau là et le projet
est confié à mes prédécesseurs patrice
bonnet qui va avoir le génie de
comprendre que restaurer le bâtiment
dans l'état où il était parvenu c'est
faire en sorte de lui conserver tous les
défauts qui avait conduit à sa ruine et
donc il ne va pas faire une restauration
seulement conservatoire au restauratrice
il va exprimer que ce hameau était à la
fois un bâtiment de marie antoinette et
un bâtiment pour l'impératrice
marie-louise et donc c'est patrice binet
qui va rétablir ces jardiner qui va
couper les grands arbres qui va rétablir
l'escalier hélicoïdal qui est la
célébrité du hameau et qui est en fait
une restitution des années 1932 33 et de
nouveau après cette étape de
restauration le bâtiment était dégradée
il n'avait jamais été ouvert au public
et c'est tout ce qu'il a fallu remettre
en état et enfin meublé pour le
présenter bientôt visiteurs et tout ça
justement ça mêlera des visites guidées
qui rouvriront le 12 mai merci beaucoup
jacques moulin ils en ont fait tout un
cinéma cinq comédiens et un musicien
réinvente le septième art déclic théâtre
jouée la semaine dernière une nouvelle
mouture de leur spectacle
d'improvisation clan ses reportages
de la formule 1 sur une musique du film
flashdance un mélange des genres que
vous propose la troupe de déclic théâtre
avec son spectacle plan c'est donner
l'illusion spectateurs qu'ils sont au
cinéma à travers des improvisations de
20 minutes
le concept le public choisit une image
une musique ainsi qu'un titre
les comédiens parts de ces trois
éléments pour en faire une histoire
comédie drame western
les possibilités sont multiples ce qui a
demandé un gros travail de préparation
pour la troupe nom s'est réuni on a
regardé plein western on a regardé plein
de films policiers on en fait on a voilà
on a essayé de se créer vraiment une
culture commune pour les comédiens de
l'ansé pour que quand on se dise ok on
va jouer à un thriller et ben on a tous
la même référence de thriller et on sait
où on part les premières choses qu'on se
dit c'est récupérer les codes assez
rapidement pour que ça parle à
l'imaginaire commun des spectateurs pour
que en fait ils puissent se dire c'est
vrai que c'est les trams des westerns
habituel et on reconnaît le genre de
film un spectacle d'une heure quinze qui
aura nécessité un an et demi de
réflexion
on est dans un dans un format qui permet
au public de voir de voir plusieurs
facettes de ce qu'on peut travailler on
n'est pas frustré si on vient voir
voilà une impro qui dure une heure et
demie ou une heure et que finalement ce
soit juste une impro complètement
dramatique et puis qu'on n'ait pas
trouvé ce qu'on est venu chercher
donc on s'est dit voilà au moins avec 3
un pro il y en a il ya en a pour tout le
monde
le spectacle se joue dans les cinémas de
proximité prochain rendez vous le 10
juin à saint cyr l'école
[Musique]
pour le coup de coeur de la semaine on
se rend à l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois c'est marilyn pukki
vous donne un rendez vous le coup de
coeur de l'espace philippe noiret cette
semaine c'est le film qui ns qui a une
fresque à la mémoire de rodney king qui
est un jeune afro-américain qui avait
été passé à tabac par des policiers qui
ont été relâchés et ce qui a donné lieu
six jours d'insurrection à los angeles
en 1992 à la réalisatrice est une
réalisatrice franco turque
denise gamme et given qui avait réalisé
un très très beau premier film must ans
qui avait été très remarquée et qui a
été choisie par la france pour présenter
les oscars
donc là avec ce film elle elle mélange
l'intimé le social comme elle mélange la
fiction et les images d archives pour à
nouveau film et le groupe et la
solidarité
pour terminer on va pas bouder notre
plaisir puisqu'elle donne une jolie
partition à halle berry et daniel craig
voilà je vous conseille ce film qu'on
joue cette semaine en version originale
la piraterie thème politique et poétique
au coeur du théâtre deux collectifs ont
inventé des protocoles de création
autour de cette thématique
à découvrir au théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les 10 et 11
mai prochains
après plusieurs mois de répétitions ils
sont enfin prêts le centre de musique
baroque de versailles et les différents
acteurs de génération lully se retrouve
sur les planches de la merise le 15 mai
prochain pour montrer leurs créations
baptiste où l'opéra des farceurs c'est
la fin de ce site une culture merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve mercredi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]